I can't talk to fish what could we do
with that that's cool maybe a commander
an army of billions in the ocean hi
everyone its charlie these were gonna be
all my Shazam Easter eggs hopefully
you've had a chance to see the movie
they represent all kinds of comic-book
things also things from the other movies
recently the DC EU as well as other
things that the director and the actors
had worked on there's so much big stuff
coming up we're still doing that IMAX
take a giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite Shazam moment on the video so
we'll stay careful for spoilers from the
movie if you haven't seen it because
we'll be talking about all kinds of
details as well as what happens at the
end of the movie starting at the
beginning of the movie working our way
to the end so at the beginning of the
movie you get dr. sivanna's backstory
you notice that his father is played by
one Jonathan Glover who was Lionel
Luthor on the Smallville TV series
keeping the cameos in the family when
he's transported to the rock of eternity
you see the seven deadly sins which are
right out of the Shazam comics what they
did was is give him a version of the
black Adams story from the new 52 Geoff
Johns run so black Adam was a big part
of that story he tries to release the
seven deadly sins in this version of
events dr. sivana learns about magic as
a child and continues to seek out the
seven deadly sins to take their power
but knows nothing about Black Adam
whereas in the new 52 version he is the
one who released Black Adam from his
imprisonment who then goes on to try and
release the seven deadly sins and you
get that big ending at the amusement
park that you got a version of during
the Shazam movie the wizard Shazam being
played by Djimon Honsou the coincidence
being is that he was also in the Captain
Marvel movie which was released in the
same month as Korath a younger version
of the character so he was in two
different Captain Marvel movies released
in the same month which is just a huge
coincidence but at the beginning of the
movie when Billie tricks the police
officers into breaking into that pawn
shop you see an Annabel creation doll on
the shelf that's the movie that the
director who directed Shazam did before
this when billy gets arrested and taken
in to Family Services on the desk of the
woman who's talking to him is a smiley
face from The Watchmen comics if he
didn't know they're gonna be doing a
Watchmen TV series on HBO that'll
premiere later this summer there were a
ton of talky tawny tiger references
throughout the film he had a tiger on
his backpack which is a reference to
that but they also revealed that they're
going to be heading into the
magic lands in the sequel in in the
recent rebirth comics talkie Thani that
tiger people that he belongs to are from
the magic lands so we might actually
meet the literal talking tiger during
one of the sequels when they're fighting
the seven deadly sins in the amusement
park later in the film he gives one of
the stuffed Tigers to the little kid his
mother also tries to win him one in a
similar game during the flashbacks there
were a whole bunch of Batman and
Superman references but one of the
newspapers with the Superman headlines
is actually a headline from Christopher
Reeves 1978 Superman movie they did say
that they were going for the tone of
that mixed with the big movie so while a
lot of the DC references were to the
recent films like Henry Cavill Superman
suit and those characters they also
referenced a lot of stuff from the
classic Superman films later in the film
they confirmed that he's met the Justice
League when Superman comes to eat lunch
with them or bring them dessert paying
off the line that the bullies threw at
Freddie earlier in the film the reason
why they said they didn't show his face
is because they wanted to use Henry
Cavill in his schedule just didn't work
out for that cameo they wrote lines of
dialogue but they actually liked it the
way it went down because it's all about
Freddie's reaction and it would have
been a little bit different if Henry
Cavill had launched into this big speech
when he sat down you all spotted
Freddie's bullet that bounced off of
Superman he claims his authentic
probably worth five hundred dollars he
says there's a replica batarangs from
Batman vs Superman there's all the
superhero t-shirts that Freddie wears he
wears an Aquaman t-shirt with Jason
Momoa as Aquaman symbol on it presumably
this is taking place after the events or
concurrently with the events of the
Aquaman movie but because it's around
Christmastime I'm assuming it's after
Aquaman there's also the Time magazine
reference from the Kryptonian invasion
during the Man of Steel movie he has all
kinds of action figures most of the
Superman emblems are from Henry cabals
but when they're in the toy shop you see
all kinds of DC direct toys that you can
actually go out and buy right now a lot
of those toys are real toys based on the
Justice League characters the voice of
Batman when he throws the Batman figure
at dr. sivana and says go get him Batman
is actually one of the people that
worked on the film it's not really Kevin
Conroy as we had previously believed
when both doctor Sivan at the beginning
of the movie and then later Billie enter
the rock of eternity inside the entrance
you see a bunch of magical artifacts
strewn about
most notably mr. mind who makes an
appearance at the end of the film when
he comes to dr. sivana after he escapes
but you also spot those magic mirrors it
looks like it's right out of Snow White
there's actually someone who lives in
the mirror called Francesca in the
comics they might bring into one of the
sequels but a lot of those magical
artifacts are just meant to be Easter
eggs there were a lot of people that
thought that they spotted the helmet of
fate but I don't think that that's
anywhere in the background of these
shots but you do spot this magical
sceptre in the background here this also
in the background of this shot called
the it stick which belonged to Edith the
invincible the burning violin that you
also see in there is also a reference to
a former pupil of the wizard Shazam from
the classic Shazam comics that appeared
during Captain Marvel Adventures number
64 he was a person named agar he
enchants a violin to set fire whenever
someone plays it gives it to one of his
henchmen and they use it to burn down
New York City the wizard Shazam gives
Billy a very magical PowerPoint
presentation on Black Adam in the
history of the rock of eternity in the
magical council they make no reference
to where he is in present day but they
say that they wrongly gave him their
powers he unleashed the seven deadly
sins to get revenge on man for the death
of his wife and they barely fought him
off at the cost of all of his brothers
and sisters presumably they also subdued
black Adam and he will be released
during the Black Adam movie the high
school that they go to is called Fawcett
central which is a reference to Fawcett
comics the original publication that
told the Shazam stories when he was
still called Captain Marvel when they
cut class to go test Billy's powers the
abandoned warehouse that they go to is
an ace chemicals abandoned warehouse
which is a reference to the Joker in the
Batman comics when they're trying to
come up with funny names for Billy they
make a couple Marvel references captain
Sparkle fingers is actually a female
Captain Marvel reference Kelly pseudo
Connick during her run called Carol
Danvers Princess sparkle fists a couple
times then you also hear someone try to
call Billy zapped in America as in
Captain America when they're at the real
estate agents office trying to find the
superhero lair they make a couple
references to the Christopher Nolan
Batcave yeah we're looking for a cave
with a water far wall flowing over with
a cave that we can jump into just like
the Batcave during the Dark Knight
trilogy there are a couple really big
Rocky movie references so they climb the
steps of the museum they talk about
rocky a little bit now
get what rocky was talking about when
he's looking at the view then later he's
busking on the steps doing the lightning
hands while the song I have the tiger
from the Rocky movies is playing which
you can also call a reference to talky
tawny the talking tiger like I said just
another one of the many many Tiger
references throughout Shazam Game of
Thrones season 8 is starting this
weekend Freddy makes the game of Thrones
reference when he's joking about why he
can't walk he holds up his cane and says
oh don't let these other people for you
it gets real Game of Thrones around here
making a joke about being pushed out the
window like bran stark things I do for
love like I said they were trying to
make a superman movie cross with Tom
Hanks big they actually do the giant
keyboard moment from the big movie when
dr. sivana is chasing him out of the
store and they both run across that
giant keyboard Billie's mother's name
Cece Batson is actually a reference to
CC Beck who was one of the creators of
Captain Marvel when he was at Fawcett
comics you wonder why there are seven
chairs for the magical council but there
are only six members of the Shazam
family the seventh member is actually
someone from the rebirth comics who
claims to be the lost seventh member of
the Shazam family so maybe they'll pay
that off in the next film but I also
believed that David Sandberg the
director may have cameoed when they were
doing the scene with Billy's mother when
he tries to go to her apartment building
and there's the boyfriend in the
background yelling at her off-screen I
think that that's the director when
they're opening all the doors to the
different planes of existence in the
different dimensions inside the rock of
eternity you see what looks like a
crocodile playing cards with a bunch of
other monsters that's a reference to the
crocodile men that the classic version
of Captain Marvel fought in the comics
it also sort of loops back around to mr.
mind - because mr. mine was originally
part of the monster Society of evil one
of the crocodile people was also a
member of that evil team-up like I said
at the end of the movie when dr. sivana
is in his cell and mr. mine comes to
visit him and says the seven realms are
about to be ours he's talking about the
seven realms of magic the magic lands
which are actually happening right now
in the current comics we've only got a
little bit of them but black Adam
actually just appeared during that
storyline so if they want to keep the
sequels just localized to the magic
lands then they could always introduce
black Adam that way the moment at the
end of the film when he gives the Shazam
family their powers is right out of the
comics but like I said in the original
new 52 version
of that story it was black Adam that
they were fighting during that moment
not dr. sivana some of these Easter eggs
were like three levels deep - it gets
super meta so Adam Brody is playing the
adult super version of Freddy Freeman
which i think is a perfect casting they
both have the exact same personality but
if you remember Adam Brody was
originally cast as the Barry Allen flash
during Justice League mortal which was a
movie that never ended up happening so
the sort of bringing it around Bowl
circle even taunts the seven deadly sins
saying I've studied every single
superhero move so just a reference to
all the stuff that he almost did when he
was once upon a time the Barry Allen
flash when Superman comes to eat lunch
with them at the end of the film the way
I take it is is that a little bit of
time has gone by enough for Billy to go
seek out the Justice League he's
probably met with Superman he's probably
met Wonder Woman Aquaman the other
members so is that enough time to get to
know Superman well enough to convince
him to come eat lunch at a kids high
school which is not something that
Superman would typically do for anybody
but it is Henry Cavill Superman suit
obviously this is a body double because
it's not really Henry Cavill standing
there but that's who it's meant to be
there were all kinds of other minor
references like they talked about
leaping tall buildings in a single bound
all the different powers that they try
to test him with fire immunity
super-strength they're basically going
down the list of all the powers of the
Justice League characters and at the end
of the film the very last post-credit
scene he says well I can't talk to fish
what can we do with that Freddy gets all
exasperated and tugs on his Aquaman
shirt oh I don't know you know summon an
army of fish he goes oh well that's not
that cool Jason Momoa in real life
already said that he loves the Shazam
movies so he probably laughed pretty
hard when he saw it the first time but
I'm sure that in some sequel they'll
find a way to pay off other big Justice
League cameos and references so if it
wasn't clear they now have the Shazam
family
technically they probably have enough
that they don't need to cross him over
with the other characters but I think
that everybody hopes to someday see him
in a Justice League film but if you
spotted any other really big Easter eggs
for the comics or anything else from the
other movies just write them below in
the comments in related DC news the
flash TV show is back next week the
episode is called Godspeed they're
probably gonna do a version of Godspeed
on it so look out for that Game of
Thrones is starting this weekend I'll be
doing videos for that all season long
and obviously there's all the Marvel
Avengers end game stuff happening
congratulations to the flow you're the
giveaway winner for my last big DC video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here to watch the rock explain what's
going on with Black Adam inside the DC
EU in the Black Adam movie he teases a
whole bunch of stuff and click here for
my brand new Avengers endgame Hawkeye
video thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you